voilà dyslexie dyspraxie dyscalculie en
quelques années le vocabulaire pour
décrire toutes ces difficultés
d'apprentissage à l'école n'a cessé de
s'enrichir troubles maladie handicap à
quoi correspondent vraiment tous ces
mots on va en parler quelles sont les
raisons de l'émergence de ce que sylvie
perrin dans ce film appelle une épidémie
de 10 qu'y at-il derrière tout cela
l'inquiétude des parents une tendance
peut-être à trop diagnostiquer et puis
qu'est-ce que cela dit du fonctionnement
de l'école de nous autres adultes
est ce que ces troubles disparaissent au
fil des années pour approfondir tout ce
qu'on a vu dans ce film nos enfants
troubles de sylvie perrin j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir sur ce plateau à la
marque bonjour vous êtes la présidente
de l'association adultes professionnels
et parents dyslexiques associés vous
êtes vous même maman d'un enfant 10 vous
nous en dire est un petit peu plus à un
garçon qui a une douzaine d'années
aujourd'hui
bonjour avoue corinne picariello bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
orthophoniste au chu de nîmes dans le
service de pédiatrie membres de
l'association de prévention en
orthophonie vous traiter ses petits
patients qui souffrent de ces troubles
dys bonjour avoue gilles vernets bonjour
vous êtes enseignant à paris en primaire
vous partiriez vous une forme de
pédagogie bienveillante inclusive au
quotidien et vous aider vous aussi ses
enfants 10 à trouver leur place dans le
système scolaire ce n'est pas toujours
facile vous êtes l'auteur d'un livre
intitulé tout l'or du monde aux éditions
bayard et puis enfin depuis la suisse
alessandro elia bonjour bonjour vous
êtes un psychologue psychothérapeute
cofondateur des centres sésame qui
propose des consultations des formations
à destination de ses enfants vous nous
en direz plus et vous avez co écrit avec
emmanuel pic est que l'on voit dans ce
film un livre nos enfants sous
microscope publié aux éditions payot
alors je voudrais peut-être d'abord
commencé par une réaction très simple à
la marque à ce que l'on vient d'entendre
est ce que l'on vient de voir dans ce
film est ce que vous avez été touchés
vous comme maman de ce que vous avez vu
notamment de ses parents où je disais
qu'ils étaient très démunis j'imagine
que vous y êtes retrouvé tout à fait
qu'en tant que parents et quand on se
trouve totalement démuni quand on se
passe en fait ce qu'un autre enfant
parce qu'il ya des difficultés qui
apparaissent on se fait convoquer par
l'école et tout donc on se dit mais mais
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est donc en
soit on essaie de chercher sur internet
soit on essaie de se renseigner auprès
de près de l'école l'école et c'est
aussi de nous accompagner en disant
d'aller éventuellement d'aller voir une
orthophoniste ce qu'on a fait au premier
c'est qu'on est parti voir notre médecin
traitant qui nous a fait 1
une ordonnance pour aller voir un autre
sauf aunis qui a fait nous a dit qu'il
fallait qu'un suivi orthophonique comme
on le voit bien dans le film d'ailleurs
c'est quelque chose qu'on découvre
progressivement au lycée ça tout à faire
non c'est pas que ça va être après un
parcours du combattant pour nous en tant
que parent marcourt de combat passé
c'est un parcours du combattant
alessandro elia on a on a entendu
beaucoup de mots dans ce sens ce film
dyslexie dyspraxie dyscalculie
dysorthographie saint saëns de m tout
cela dans le même sac si j'ose dire mais
c'est une manière possible de de
comprendre les choses donc oui à partir
du moment où un enfant est en souffrance
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à s'adapter
à un contexte bien on va chercher des
moyens pour l'aider à s'adapter à ces
contextes et et comme nous et humains
avons 10 nombre tendance à vouloir ordre
et les choses pour pouvoir réduire la
complexité bien effectivement cherche
des recherches des mougères des
étiquettes qui ne doivent pas dissimuler
la souffrance il ya il y avait forcément
une souffrance une souffrance parfois
des adultes il va les encadrer les
parents notamment
il ya une souffrance de l'enfant qui
finalement au fur et à mesure qu'ils
évoluent dans un contexte normatif comme
les l'école n'arrive pas à s'adapter
donc là aussi ça peut être ça peut
générer une souffrance et la souffrance
des rêves aussi du fait de demander
quelque chose dans le temps toujours la
même chose à un enfant par exemple un
enfant qui au des difficultés en lecture
il faut qu'ils lisent il faut qu'il y
arrive un enfant qui a du mal à se
concentrer c'est pareil il faut que tu
te concentres et ainsi de suite
corinne picariello c'est intéressant
dans ce qui vient d'être dit mais aussi
dans ce qu'on voit dans le film on a
l'impression que parfois effectivement
on s'y prend mal très mal avec les
enfants mais peut-être qu'on s'y prend
mal justement avant le diagnostic et il
me semble que c'est justement un gain
que nous apporterait le diagnostic
c'est à dire de pouvoir adapter les
relations que les pas à voir avec leurs
enfants et aussi qu'on va pouvoir dans
un schéma lundi fier et d'idéal aménager
la scolarité de ses enfants pour que ça
fatigue
son besoin de bouger
cette difficulté en lecture pour que
tout ceci justement lui soit octroyée
comment est-ce qu'on opère un tel
diagnostic à descendre aurelia est-ce
que voilà on se base sur un ressenti
j'imagine que les choses sont
aujourd'hui très normé oui alors pour ma
part je ne pratique plus le bilan
psychologique j'en ai pratiqué pendant
plusieurs années mais je me suis tourné
vers une autre forme de dead en fatiha
paraît vraiment complémentaire à celle
qui vise à diagnostiquer un enfant met
effectivement en psychologie le
diagnostic se fonde sur ce qu'on avait
le bilan psychologique avec un certain
nombre de tests avec des entretiens avec
une anamnèse et puis comment on va
croiser des regards différents la même
démarche a quelque chose à voir avec la
mémoire fait ça oui alors il ya des
tests qui permettent d'évaluer les
capacités d'attention les capacités
cognitives de mémoire et globalement une
intelligence de l'enfant et les aspects
aussi psycho affective comment est-ce
qu'on passe là je me retourne vers vous
à la marque du moment où on dit bon mon
enfant il a quelques difficultés où
l'entendait dans le film bon voilà
autrefois on disait tel ou tel il est un
peu rêveur
ça ne tient pas en place comment est-ce
qu'on passe de ce moment où on voit là
on dit cet enfant a quelques difficultés
à il a vraiment un problème qui est de
l'ordre de l'orthophonie voire de la
médecine
ben c'est que petit à petit on découvre
que notre enfant vraiment du mal à
l'école et donc ce qui fait qu'on essaie
nous en tant que parents de trouver des
solutions comprendre ce qui se passe
parce que nous pour nous entends penser
nouveau c'est à dire que c'est quelque
chose qu'on découvre après on commence
on me donnait des mots pendant commence
à dire c'est peut-être un enfant
dyslexique dyspraxiques saisi 10 kaka
c'est bien connu parce qu'on connaît pas
ses mots la même pour l'école ce sont
des mots qui sont inconnus parce que
accompagner des enfants qui ont des
troubles d'apprentissage léger ça peut
aller mais quand vous avez des enfants
qu'un des gros troupes c'est beaucoup
plus difficile quelqu'un pour mon fils
et nous en tant que parent on découvre
gilbert mais comment à la place qui est
la vôtre
là on en a le point de vue d'une maman
mais à la place qui est la vôtre en
feignant vous
vous décelez comme ça dans une classe
est-ce que vous en avez les moyens
déceler des enfants qui ont vraiment du
mal
ah oui vous voulez encore on les
desserts sur le plan comportemental des
relativement facile
et là il ya des solutions après qui
s'offrent à nous de même que d'ailleurs
sur le plan des apprentissages mais ça
distinguer si relève d'une dyslexie
forte ou d'un décalage d'un petit retard
de l'élève et c'est ça prend un peu de
temps mais on a toutes des équipes en
fait on est on fait des réunions
d'équipé dago gicon il ya les mettre
c'est à dire c'est des gens spécialisés
dans l'aide pédagogique mais il ya aussi
le médecin scolaire de psychologues
scolaires et avec eux et les tests dont
on parlait on va essayer de préciser si
ça relève d'une relative gravité on va
dire enfin de quelque chose qui
nécessite une adaptation de
l'enseignement et puis peut-être après
par exemple dans les cas comportementaux
des médicaments etc
mais ça ça relève pas de nous c'est nous
et après on va orienter vers un médecin
est juste tenais à dire une chose très
importante parce que je vois le parcours
du combattant que ça peut être pour
certains parents et nous en tant
qu'enseignant ce qu'on constate c'est
une carence d'orthophonistes tout
simplement pour faire le travail avec
les enfants que nous en ton prof
on peut faire un peu en aide pédagogique
mais on n'a pas vraiment le temps c'est
vraiment des heures qu'il faut consacrer
à sa 1re peut-être sur ce terme qui est
employé à plusieurs reprises dans le
film on parle de handicap et on
s'intéresse d'ailleurs dans le film
quant à savoir si c'est vraiment adapté
est ce que voilà ce sont des enfants qui
souffrent d'un handicap parce que c'est
pas un peu stigmatisant aussi ce terme
là je vous pose la question à vous allez
sandro il ya ça peut l'être
en effet ça peut ça peut être
stigmatisant et en même temps on ne nie
pas que pour certains enfants ce soir un
réel handicap d'accéder à certains
apprentissages moi la question que je me
pose plus tôt et pour rebondir sur ce
que
vous disiez tout à l'heure gilbert n'est
sûr dans le fond la carence
d'orthophonistes peut-être aussi qu'il
il a vu qu'il ya une tendance assure
diagnostic et d'une certaine manière a
cherché très vite le trouble et bien
beaucoup d'enfants doivent consulter et
finalement les ressources manquent
et dans ce cas on ne peut pas répondre
aux enfants qui en ont vraiment besoin
c'est aussi ça notre inquiétude corps
explique ariel sur cette question du
surdiagnostic puisque est ce qu on a
diagnostiqué c'est un peu paradoxal par
rapport à ce qu'on dit au début de
l'émission
alors écoutez je trouve qu'on a déjà
tendance à chercher ce qui à mon avis
est une bonne démarche
après justement il appartient aux
professionnels de santé qui va réaliser
les tests de dire bien nous sommes dans
le trouble ou au contraire il s'agit
d'un petit décalage d'un retard scolaire
et la de proposer des solutions qui ne
seront pas des solutions de soi parce
que justement l'orthophoniste est un
professionnel du soin et il est censé
intervenir auprès des enfants qui en ont
réellement besoin et ça sera justement
un des objectifs de des premiers
rendez-vous dépôt des rendez-vous de
bilan qui servent à à apprécier la
situation
alors l'un des points très intéressants
dans ce film c'est qu'il interroge aussi
sur les causes de ce qui est appelé dans
le film une épidémie on reviendra
peut-être d'ailleurs sur ce terme il est
beaucoup question de l'école sans qu'on
y soit d'ailleurs toujours sans qu'on y
aille dans ce film mais le professeur
revol l'inde est l'un des personnages
dit quelque chose de très intéressant
sur le contraste entre ce qui se passe
dans la société dans la famille ce qui
se passe au sein de l'école regarder
puis on va en parler après tant qu'on
est dans une société où le système
scolaire impose six sept huit heures de
cours sans bouger c'est évident que une
sosie légal extérieur est hyper active
qui sur informe qu'ils surent stimule
les enfants les adolescents et qui leur
demande de rester en place en permanence
pl c'est très compliqué gilles vernet il
ya un sujet effectivement un peu grand
écart peut-être qu'on demande à des
enfants hyperactifs à l'extérieur et
puis très sage trop sage dans la salle
de classe
oui d'ailleurs c'est un phénomène plus
large dans la société c'est d'une
certaine manière des phénomènes
adoption comme ça où on demande tout et
son contraire dans la société
j'avais réalisé un film qui s'appelait
tout s'accélère avec mes élèves où
justement on mettait en question
cette frénésie de la société cette
espèce d'emballement qu'ils jouent sur
la technologie les écrans la
consommation aussi tous ces enfants
conte plein d'activités dans la semaine
et on vient dans cette société là très
clairement et et c'est pas évident comme
c'est dit dans le film pour ses enfants
surtout
je pense que le rôle clé qu'il faut
vraiment interrogés c'est les écrans
dans leur globalité et là à ce moment là
on s'aperçoit que c'est très paradoxal
les enfants qui sont soumis à des écrans
à des émotions très fort très souvent
quand on leur demande d'être calme et
posée en classe ce n'est pas toujours
facile
corinne picariello un mot justement sur
c'est ce qu'on vient d'entendre la dent
dans dans cet extrait du documentaire
est ce que c'est là une clés
d'explication dans ce qui est appelé
donc une épidémie de diagnostic de 10
une épidémie de diagnostic nous on va
dire peut-être un meilleur repérage qui
à 50 ou 60 ou quarante ans après
effectivement le rôle des écrans joue
aussi quand il y assure exposition et
puis bien entendu il ne faut pas oublier
certains facteurs environnementaux
alessandro elias a sur ce terme qu'on
emploie depuis tout à l'heure et qui
d'ailleurs je crois figure dans le sous
titre de votre livre ce terme d'épidémie
de diagnostic je voudrais que vous nous
expliquer un petit peu pourquoi vous
vous autorisez a parlé de voilà en ces
termes
oui c'est un titre de livre donc il faut
évidemment que ce soit un tout petit peu
accrocheur mais en même temps il est
vrai que de notre point de vue ce que
nous questionnons c'est plutôt le
surdiagnostic ça n'est pas la question
de diagnostic est en réalité nous
pensons emmanuel et moi que la vraie
question n'est pas de savoir si le
diagnostic est une bonne ou une mauvaise
chose
la question de savoir plus tôt s'il
permet à l'enfant d'évoluer vers une
vraie âme
y'aura sion et notre travail à nous dans
une manière de travailler qui cite à
être plus attentifs au contexte dans
lequel évolue lens et bien on va essayer
de distinguer les facteurs
environnementaux dont corinne picariello
parlais tout à l'heure des facteurs
environnementaux ici et maintenant
qu'ils peuvent avoir un impact sur les
d'adaptation de l'enfant et donc ce qui
va nous intéresser c'est de faire des
différences
parce que dans le fond un trouble ou un
handicap va se définir sur un continuum
entre ce qui est sain et ce qui est
pathologique et des fois cette limite
entre le saint et pathologie qui est
très difficile à appréhender
même pour des professionnels chevronnés
et il veut la société vous diriez que
cette limite entre ce qui est sain et
pathologique elle a évolué ces dernières
années
oui je pense que oui clairement pour
plusieurs raisons c'est que d'une
certaine façon est évidemment mon
discours ne vise pas à hardy à dire
qu'il faut retourner 40 ans en arrière
au contraire c'est absolument
fondamental qu'on est des professionnels
qui puisse distinguer les les troupes
dans les enfants peuvent souffrir donc
ça il n'y a pas de doute là dessus mais
il ya vraiment une médicalisation
croissante des inadaptations infantile
c'est à dire dans le fond l'enfant est
devenu petit à petit un patient voilà
donc beaucoup de différences
individuelles sont devenus des symptômes
de troubles psys et c'est à nous les
professionnels de la santé de faire la
différence
est ce que vous voyez gilles verdez ses
parents qui voient là qui réclament en
quelque sorte d'en savoir plus sur les
raisons des difficultés de leurs enfants
et qui parfois pardon je me brosse à
gros traits mais en espérerait presque
que ce soit de quelque chose d'ordre
médical oui ben en même temps on peut
les comprendre parce que t'es pas
toujours facile quand on se met à la
place des parents qu'avec les
difficultés rencontrées mais est ce qui
est vrai c'est que ça peut engendrer une
dramatisation et que ce que je crois je
crois beaucoup qu'il peut y avoir des
dimensions psychologiques aussi dans des
troupes quand ils sont mineurs pas trop
grave et que avec de la confiance de
l'aide et surtout avec du temps ça prend
un peu de temps souvent pour les enfants
on a vu des enfants atteints d
orthographie dyslexie dyscalculie reste
de réussir à dépasser c'est pas quelque
chose qui est toujours attaché à soi
mais comment elle est d'éviter un très
concrètement et en même temps comme
c'est dit les handicapés et c'est
important de le différer face il est là
comment vous les aider ou ses enfants
pariant sur la dyscalculie samoa bref
vous personnellement j'ai eu un cas
cette année qui m'a frappé qui était en
place 10 calculée c'est en faisant des
puissances en cm2 à dire les puissances
et dans le match c'est pas très
compliqué finalement c'est multiplier le
nombre un même nombre plusieurs fois et
les enfants le comprennent et quand je
leur ai dit que c'était au programme de
4e l'élève qui avait des difficultés
tant qu'il a il s'est aperçu qu'ils
faisaient y qui réussissait ça me le
fait de se dire c'est au point le
quatrième de gagner d'un seul coup en
confiance le la dès cliquez sur plein de
choses en maths
il ya un effet psychologique très
important je voudrais que parce qu'on en
parle depuis tout à l'heure des départs
ans il arrive que de temps en temps et
on le voit dans le film est vrai qu'on
regarde cet extrait que des parents
rechignent au contraire à diagnostiquer
à aller voir un spécialiste regardez cet
extrait puis on va en parler après tu as
et puis la primaire qu'on n'arrête pas
de me dire de le faire diagnostiquer
pense qu'il doit avoir doit être
dyslexique et puis hyperactif mais en
primaire on nous a quand même conseillé
peut-être un petit peu la ritaline
plusieurs fois on lutte pour pas faire
de diagnostic mais pourquoi vous voulez
pas faire des diagnostics
maintenant j'ai peur qu'après ils soient
étiquetés quoi la course diagnostic
d'une certaine manière
bah ça nous ça nous dédouane parce que
ça rend la vie plus facile de mettre les
choses dans des cases et avec des
étiquettes parce que comme ça on n'a
plus trop de questions à se poser sur en
effet la façon qu'on a d'être au monde
la façon qu'on a d'être avec nos enfants
puisqu'au fond c'est pas de notre faute
à nous adultes
c'est lui qui dans sa tête un problème
cette cette crainte à la marque qui est
exprimé par par une maman dans l'extrait
qu'on vient de voir deux que son enfant
soit stigmatisée en quelque sorte par
par ce diagnostic vous l'avez prouvé
vous pas
pas quand on est contre les parents
qu'on connaît pas oui le stigmatisation
on a peur de l'étiquette mais parce
qu'on a enfin à plusieurs autres enfants
qui ont qui savent face à roux lors
qu'on va dire il roulait et puis tout
d'un coup on se retrouve avec un enfant
qui a des difficultés on dit bon bah
ferme d'un diagnostic après après c'est
quelle étiquette il va voir parce que
malgré tout c'est quand on diagnostiqué
et que d'art pour le cas de monfils qui
lui et c'est un handicap est un handicap
c'est une étiquette qui qui garde parce
que c'est un peu particulier 5 du 29
c'est à dire que mon fils a eu à partir
du cm1 il a été on lui a attribué une
avs c'est là ça a été la même à la une
assistante de vie scolaire et là les
enfin les enfants sont pas tendres entre
eux et j'ai eu de la chance c'est qu'on
avait des enseignants bienveillant qui
ont su la compagnie qui ont suis
expliquée aux enfants que c'était n'est
pas c'était pas un plus c'était juste
mais pour pour certains enfants c'est il
a des choses en plus il peut avoir des
points plus grâce à elle ou quoi que ce
soit les ils ont l'impression que leurs
camarades et un peu le chouchou moyens
villégier c'est ça alors que c'est pas
du tout le progrès ligier parce que ces
enfants là quand vous leur mettez une
avs sais c'est pas pour forcément gaieté
de coeur qui s'est vraiment qu'ils en
ont besoin
corinne picariello un mot sur les
parents que que vous vous voyez ils sont
ils sont parfois confond les parents à
bout alors déjà je voudrais réagir un
petit peu à ce qui s'est dit
précédemment je trouve que madame marca
a prononcé un mot important qui le mot
bienveillance et le discours de monsieur
vernet me semble aussi extrêmement
bienveillant et il me semble que dans la
bienveillance effectivement tous les
enfants peuvent progresser y compris les
enfants de 10 et si le monde et
notamment le monde scolaire était un peu
plus bienveillants on aurait peut-être
moins besoin de nous orthophoniste en
tout cas et pour ce qui est de cette
humanisation que la maman du film
semblait craindre je je je comprends son
interrogation mais il faut dire que les
enfants entendent les accusations de
paresse
ils vident un échec scolaire ils vivent
une souffrance au quotidien avec aussi
et les moqueries ou les accusations de
leurs camarades et ça stigmatise aussi
et plus douloureusement peut-être qu'un
diagnostic il fait la part des choses
entre un trouble spécifique
il va toucher une difficulté circonscrit
et leur intelligence
alessandro elia sur ce sujet oui je suis
aussi je rencontre tous les jours des
départs ans qui viennent en consultation
chez chez nous et je vois aussi à quel
point ils sont difficultés parce que
dans le fond ses parents sont inquiets
et reçoivent souvent des injonctions des
pressions pour consulter un pour qu'ils
consultent pour leurs enfants et pour
avoir de l'aide il faut un diagnostic et
donc c'est souvent le seul moyen qui est
proposé aux parents pour sortir d'une
situation difficile et si et si je me
mets à leur place
moi je serais perdu aussi parce que je
me dirais mais à quelle porte il faut
aller frapper il ya quelque chose de
très intéressant dans ce que dit
emmanuel pic est dans ce qu'on a entendu
dans l'extrait c'est où est-ce qu'on
doit mettre le curseur de l'aide au sein
de au sein de la classe par exemple elle
dit là encore à gros traits si jamais on
donne un avs c'est très bien mais dans
la vraie vie entre guillemets ses
enfants quand ils seront adultes ils
n'auront pas ils n'auront pas cette aide
là gilles vernets voilà il faut que ces
aides existent mais qu'elles soient
ponctuels c'est surtout que ça dépend
des cas mais je crois déjà que les
diagnostics ou le fait de pouvoir bien
comprendre les soucis cas l'élève ça
permet quand même apporter des solutions
des pistes de solution et pour
l'enseignant d'aménager la présence des
abbés sql pour des enfants avec des eaux
troubles comportementaux très important
pour à la fois la paix dans la classe et
pour l'épanouissement de l'enfant
moi j'ai eu un cas que je relate dans le
livre mais qui était extrêmement
touchant d'un enfant qui était employé
en grande difficulté et et la présence
de la veille
c'est le fait d'avoir adapté l'autre
enseignement pour lui donner des choses
alors je suis en cm2 plutôt de c1 ou co2
mais dans lequel il réussissait il avait
des traits bien la ré enclenché dans un
processus de conscience qu'il a aidé
alors ce n'est pas miraculeux mais il ya
vraiment une part de confiance et aussi
un rôle de l'enseignant est très
important c'est d'imposer à la classe le
respect des différences pas devenir de
deux des différents niveaux et le fait
que les élèves et certains élèves
doivent être aisé à la limite tout le
monde en profite à la marque peut-être
sur ce qui a été dit dans l'extrait est
sûre voilà le risque qui est pointée par
emmanuel piqué aidons ces enfants bien
sûr mais attention à ne pas non plus
faire comme si ça allait se passer comme
ça dans le monde des adultes
oui mais il faut savoir que quand vous
avez une avait sa chance quand ils sont
à dos les enfants n'en veulent plus
parce que pour eux c'est un boulet comme
ça c'est ce que disait depuis par des
ados et puis à plus grands 10 puis le
regarder des de l'adulte
d autres les autres donc il va être être
comme tout donc on a beaucoup d'enfants
qui arrivait au lycée ne veulent plus
entendre parler d'accompagnement comme
le ppa le pap qui peut être mis en place
quoi que ce soit donc ce que je veux
dire c'est que pour revenir sur
l'enseignement nous ce qu'on dise nous
parents ces cas pas forcément besoin
toujours d'une avs ou que c'est juste
d'appliquer la pédagogie différenciée
comme ça devrait être fait et
d'accompagner ses ailes parce que tous
les élèves ont plus ou moins besoin
d'accompagnement et si on appliquait à
pédagogie différenciée et ne pas dire
aux enfants
t'as vu ta mauvaise note ou t'as vu tes
ce que je redis c'est la bienveillance
derozan alors tu as réussi même si la
pédagogie différenciée c'est très bien
mais la question s'il ya dans la classe
voilà dix enfants qui ont tous feront
chacun d'une particularité c'est quand
même pour un pour un enseignant c'est
très compliqué c'est très compliqué mais
c'est écrit
normalement dans les textes oui mais il
ya une chose que ça il faudrait après et
après je comprends qu'il ya aussi un
problème d'un manque de formation des
enseignants parce que moi pour ça je
sais quelques 10 heures de formation sur
tout ce qui est trouble c'est peu pour
les pubs pour les enseignants c'est à
eux de se former tout seul derrière
parlons en terme de résultat qu'une
picariello voilà le fait d'avoir un
enfant qui a une assistante de vie
scolaire on voit les résultats vous
comme orthophoniste vous voyez la
différence assez rapidement alors on
voit l'on voit les résultats qu'il ya
une assistante de vie scolaire oui mais
on voit surtout le résultat d'un travail
généralement pluridisciplinaire le
travail des différents professionnels le
travail que font les enseignants tant
qu'ils sont sensibilisés aux troubles de
sept enfants est aussi tout ce que les
parents mettent en place parce que il
faut quand même avoir à l'esprit c'est
que ce diagnostic il va faire changer le
climat familial quand les parents
comprennent ce qui se passe quand
l'enfant lui même on prend ce qui lui
arrive
tout le monde se met au travail en fait
et on peut cibler le travail est ce que
c'est un travail orthophoniste est ce
que c'est un travail plutôt de
psychothérapie à faire parce que il ya
des choses à mettre au clair ça a tout à
fait sa place
et puis une fois que tout le monde a
l'impression qui peut avancer fait que
chaque personne a l'impression qu'elle
peut avancer
et ben oui les progrès sont là et
l'assistante de vie scolaire elle va
voir sa tâche bien définie et petit à
petit l'équipe pédagogique d'un
réfléchir au fait de retirer
progressivement cette assistante
j'oublie ce que l'on fait est relatif
tant de vie scolaire c'est ce qui fait
face petit lien est bien c'est que
l'enfant acquiert des stratégies par lui
même enfin grâce à toutes les aides qui
lui sont données et qu'après ils les
utilisent par lui même donc en fait le
but
les aides s'est petit à petit d'être de
disparaître et dès qu'on les donne on
sait qu'on va réfléchir à leur retrait
mais de manière personnalisée à
l'éteindre
voilà l'enfant il faut qu'ils acquièrent
des stratégies comme on dit on en guérit
de flat on peut voilà arrivés au monde
adulte en ayant atténué ses difficultés
bien sûr je pense qu'on peut bien sûr
trouver des stratégies mais je voulais
peut-être quand même juste rebondir sur
ce que vient de dire quand même
picariello parce que nous nous avons
quand même en consultation beaucoup de
parents qui viennent et qui amène le
diagnostic de leurs enfants et qu'ils
nous disent
malgré le diagnostic malgré les aides
les choses n'ont pas évolué voire se
sont aggravées et nous ce sont ces
situations là qui nous questionnent
puisque lorsque l'aviation
comment s y sont nombreuses situations
oui oui oui oui oui c'est pour ça qu'on
a écrit ce livre parce que ça nous a
interrogés d'un point de vue clinique et
donc je pense que c'est quand même
important de le dire c'est à dire que si
l'aide est que une avs chez nous ça
s'appelle différemment mais peu importe
ensuite on a aussi ce type est dans les
écoles si cette aide est dès que
l'enfant progresse petit à petit qu'ils
se saisit de ses ressources
on n'a aucun problème on est content le
problème c'est que souvent cette aide il
arrive que c'était de n'être pas et que
l'enfant s'enferme et qu'on s'enferme
dans cette situation
lorsqu'on appelle non un paradoxe de
l'aide c'est à dire que plus on la nomme
- il se sent lui responsable de ces
apprentissages et donc là en yards il ya
il ya un vrai risque aussi à souligner
et il ne s'agit pas de dénoncer l'aide
au contraire on a besoin de ces et de
l'amif il faut
prennent ce que l'on appelle dans notre
langage systémique le feedback c'est à
dire le retour d'information est ce que
cette aide finalement aide et j'aime
beaucoup ce que dit corinne picariello
qu'antenne quand vous dites d'enfants on
pense déjà à arrêter l'aide au moment où
on la met en place on se dit qu'elles
seront les indicateurs qui nous
permettront de dire voilà on a aidé sept
enfants maintenant on va s'arrêter et on
va le remettre dans un circuit
écologique où il va essayer de se
débrouiller lui-même
je retiens quelque chose de ce que vous
venez de dire chacun sait que et là
dessus j'ai le vernet devrait votre
réaction c'est c'est vraiment un travail
d'équipé
c'est un travail qui implique la famille
les enseignants
voilà lé praticien absolument le rôle de
la famille et le lien entre l'enseignant
mais aussi les structures dead et de
diagnostic est très importante pour
qu'on puisse avancer et comme ça a été
dit faire de l'enseignement différencié
ce terreau de stress pression pendant
quelques instants dans la matinée avec
les élèves sur une tâche à part on voit
les progrès c'est toujours ce lien qui
se fait mais j'ai trouvé intéressante
mais aussi de rebondir sur le fait que
finalement l'enfant peut s'enfermer dans
une forme de facilités parce que ça je
l' ai vu aussi il ya une espèce de
balance à trouver entre l'aide et le
fait de pousser à l'autonomie à la
valorisation de l'enfant croire dans le
fait qu'il va y arriver et l'y pousser
parfois un petit peu avec virulence quoi
parce qu'il y en a qui peuvent
s'endormir dans voilà alessandro il ya
on me pose souvent on vend de la
question en sortant de ce film on se
demande si voilà ce que deviennent ces
enfants quand ils grandissent d'abord je
disais c'est quand même un phénomène
assez récent on a depuis quelques
décennies seulement pris conscience et
puis mis des termes sur sur toutes ces
difficultés comment aujourd'hui voilà
grandi ces enfants est ce qu'ils
arrivent entre guillemets je fais
attention à ce que je vis mal à entrer
dans la norme
oui et c'est une question intéressante
la question de la norme aussi puisque
l'on se rend compte que la norme devient
de plus en plus étroite et qu'on laisse
de moins en moins de temps j'ai regardé
la très jolie conférence tedx de gilles
vernet et je trouvais très intéressant
de considérer que si dense on laisse du
temps aux enfants est bien petit à petit
ils peuvent y arriver
simplement on voudrait que comme comme
une culture de céréales il pousse au
même moment et à la même hauteur et au
même endroit en plus donc ça c'est un
vrai problème donc la question de la
norme
si on arrivait à plutôt que d'interroger
toujours l'enfant en termes de déficit
si on interrogeait aussi en le système
en termes d'un système qui ne fonctionne
pas en fait ou qui est qui est pas
finalement adapté
ça c'est déjà une première chose
maintenant c'est vrai que pour répondre
à votre question pour la suite
nous on a mené une reçu une j'ai mené
une recherche avec des étudiants de
l'université de lausanne où on regarde
et finalement comment vivaient les le
des adultes qui avaient été
diagnostiqués enfants comment ils
vivaient ce diagnostic l'âge adulte en
fait et j'étais vraiment frappé par une
chose c'est une forme d'identification
diagnostic c'est ce qui revenait parfois
le diagnostic les a aidés et d'autres
fois pas mais en tout cas
systématiquement ce qui revenait c'était
je suis tdh j'ai un trouble de
l'attention
je suis dis pas que c'est la tension est
donc évidente y fier à son instinct
troubles oui c'était ce qui ressortait
de cette recherche et pour toute la vie
alors pour le cadre de la recherche que
simon n'ait pas où il ya plus mais
c'était intéressant de voir comment
d'autres ressources n'émergeait
peut-être pas à ce moment là et que
c'était principalement l'asp est
déficitaire qui émergeait corinne
picariello donnez nous un peu d'espoir
dans vos anciens patients vous en avez
peut-être là des contacts avec des
adultes qui ont souffert de sa voix là
on s'intègre on parvient à faire son
trou sa place alors j'ai plusieurs
choses à dire d'abord pour ce qui est de
la vs et puis du fait de demander à
l'enfant de se mettre au travail
je pense que le rôle de l'enseignant est
indispensable parce que lui il voit
l'enfant et il voit très bien aux
moments quand l'enfant sait se mettre au
travail et quand l'enfant se repose sur
son auxiliaire de vie scolaire donc
le regard de l'enseignant est
indispensable justement pour ajuster les
led et éventuellement la retirer pour
que l'enfant sache que là et bien il est
de confronter une réalité de travail
pour ce qui est ensuite de cette
omniprésence du diagnostic
alors il se peut très bien je ne
conteste pas du tout la vision de
monsieur vernet ou de non pardon de
monsieur il ya oui madame pitié mais
j'ai peut-être une autre
un autre éclairage qui est que quand on
est porteur de troubles et je vous le
dis parce que moi je suis porteur de
troubles de dyscalculie ça c'est assez
particulier et quand on sait qu'on a ce
trouble on a comme une grille de lecture
de soi même donc peut-être que ces gens
que vous avez rencontré le vivier de
manière très négative mais on peut aussi
le voir de manière éclairante sur sa
propre particularité mais lors donc
sûrement pas chez vous allez tourner je
voulais vraiment là sur vos patients
adultes voilà est-ce que mes anciens
patients
j'ai des pharmaciennes des pharmaciens
des médecins une assistante sociale
j'ai un pâtissier meilleur ouvrier de
france j'ai un boucher est le dernier en
date c'est un jeune ingénieur des eaux
qui est venu me voir la semaine dernière
je lui ai dit mais vraiment samuel la
dyslexie
au quotidien elle te gêne ab oui elle me
gêne c'est relou mais on se connaît et
on avance ceux là dessus mais peut-être
le mot de la fin à la marque vous êtes
vous inquiète pour votre enfant se fait
toujours de l'inquiétude pour nier
inquiet mais on essaye de l'accompagner
dans ce qu'il veut faire plus tard
mais ce que vous entendez là vous donne
confiance oui ou non nous on a déjà eu
des retours ça notre association
d'adultes qui me disait quand il sortait
de l'école puisque l'école énorme et il
se sentait beaucoup plus livre en
sortant de l'école parce qu'il ya moins
de normes et ce qui fait qu'ils
pouvaient faire plein de choses et ce
qui se voulait faire en plus envie s'est
sagement quand même votre votre
préoccupation agile vernet de faire en
sorte que l'école font un petit peu
moins normes et oui oui oui et
d'ailleurs un des élèves
des hyperactifs que j'ai eus qui a
vraiment été identifiés comme tels et
qui était d'ailleurs sauvé votre île
c'est un élève qui est dans le film man
ou l'opéra qui est paru qui a été
diffusé sur public sénat où mes élèves
faisait un opéra dans l'île il est dans
la dernière scène c'est lui qui dans ce
cas avec des ailes et fn dans ce
magnifique et c'était tout le travail de
toute l'école sur cinq angles avoir vu
depuis le cp où il était intenable
jusque là vous raccompagner aujourd'hui
je sais que il fait son chemin
exactement comment ça a été dit en
connaissance de cause
merci beaucoup merci à tous les quatre
de nous avoir aidés à approfondir cette
thématique qui est très actuelle je
renvoie un certain nombre de livres le
vôtre à descendre lla nos enfants sous
microscope ou comment stopper l'épidémie
de diagnostic paru aux éditions payot
gilles vernet tout l'or du monde on l'a
évoqué c'est aux éditions bayard où vous
raconter votre parcours comment après
avoir travaillé dans la finance de les
choisit de devenir enseignant quelques
exemples voilà deux livres qui s'adapte
aussi aux enfants qui souffrent de ces
troubles d'ici à la très célèbre
collection j'aime lire toujours chez
bayard ou encore d'autres titres comme
la série des aventures de niko chez
nathan merci encore à tous et à toutes
de nous avoir suivi et à très bientôt
sur public sénat
[Musique]